We know that the vertex is a special point on a parabola. Because if you
remember, there's a line of symmetry that runs right through the center of the
vertex, and divides the parabola in 2. We saw that tangent lines on opposite
sides of the parabola at the same vertical position have opposite slopes. In
other words, if we folded this parabola in half, down this side of the line, the
two halves this is divided in two right now, would match one and other
perfectly. Let's see if we can make any other general statements about the
behavior of the function on this side of the graph versus on this side the
graph. For a moment, let's just look at this right half. The corner for the
vertex as I showed you in the last problem were negative 0.75 and negative 2.25.
So for now we're just going to only consider the domain in the region where x is
greater than negative 0.75. As you can tell on the right side of the graph, as x
gets bigger, f of x gets bigger as well. So I'd like you to complete this
sentence property. On the interval of the domain negative 0.75 to infinity, so
in other words, this half of the graph we've been talking about. What is
happening to the value of the function? Is f of x increasing, decreasing, or
constant? So remember that we read graphs from left to right, so this is asking,
what is happening to the behavior of f of x, of the value of the function, the
dependent variable, as the independent variable x, increases?